foreign
so
welcome to this press conference
following the
eu canada summit good morning to
everyone bonjour
premium welcome president of the council
and the president of the commission
we'll have uh introductions by the three
speakers and then we'll take questions
both here in the room and virtually
this translation into french and english
mind you uh
president of the council please mercy
particularly so maybe
the security first topic defeating covet
19
remains our top priority the eu is the
largest exporter of vaccines and you've
exported
roughly half of our production of
vaccines
we have supported canada's vaccination
campaign
by shipping roughly 16 million doses to
canada
this represents 60 of all
vaccines received by canada and until a
few weeks ago
it was as high as 80 percent with canada
we are stepping up our efforts to ensure
universal access to vaccines diagnostics
and
treatments and the eu is a top
contributor to kovacs
with 3.2 billion euros we also
plan to share at least 100 million
dollars of vaccines
by the end of this year and we have
mobilized 1 billion euros to increase
global production of vaccines in
developing countries
we also to the decision to launch a new
canada
eu dialogue on health and when we speak
about the future
that also means being better prepared
for future pandemics
we are working together to strengthen
the who
and i welcome prime minister trudeau's
support for this idea
of an international treaty on pandemics
in the framework
of the who the eu and canada
are also bending together to ensure a
green
innovative and inclusive recovery that
creates
good shops we support global efforts to
provide
additional support to low-income
countries to recover
[Music]
um
necessary
this year we celebrate the 5th
anniversary
of the signing of sita this agreement
is good for our citizens for our
businesses
and for our economic recovery and we see
eye to eye on the need to strengthen
modernize and reform the wto for the
future
moving forward we must ensure the
security
of critical minerals and metals value
chains and we agreed
to launch an eu canada strategic
partnership
on raw materials will continue to
enhance
our cooperation research innovation and
space
location
thank you president madam president you
have the floor
thank you so much a very warm welcome to
you
justin um it's so good to have you here
in brussels
of course we did have excellent
exchanges at
g7 but meeting you here in brussels
gives us as europeans
the opportunity to let you know how much
we value our very special partnership
with canada we do share the same
interests we have the same values
we share the same world view and we have
the same understanding that it is
multilateralism
that we want to strengthen to address
today's global challenges
so indeed yesterday we explored ways to
deepen this partnership
first of all let me have a look at the
health topic
we will work hand in hand to overcome
this pandemic
and indeed the very first topic is
always vaccines
there is a high demand for global
vaccines
we want to make sure that canada knows
that you can count on us
that you can count on the european
solidarity
canada is the eu's top four export
destination for covet 19 vaccines
we have ensured an uninterrupted export
of vaccines to canada and we will
continue
of course to do so now
what we really need besides vaccines
is to be better prepared so i was very
grateful justin for your support
at the global health summit in rome
where we created
the rome declaration because by that we
now have
a roadmap to recover and to be more
prepared and better prepared
to deal with global health crisis in the
future
we need better surveillance we need
better preparedness in the
infrastructure
it would be good if we worked together
and we agreed on that
to reform wh o because
in particular we have to improve the
early warning system
and we have to improve the investigative
powers
of who because we all know that we lost
precious month at the beginning of the
pandemic
and as part of these lessons learned
yesterday we decided to launch
an eu canada dialogue on health so we
will share expertise we will share
lessons learned and practices
of that that are best practices to be
better prepared and work
closely together on these issues we also
discussed
how to ensure that new technologies
like mrna come to africa or for example
latin america
and one important step here is to find
a consensual form within the trips
agreement
so here also thank you for the
cooperation on climate change
you and canada will also work closely on
fighting climate change we count on
canada as our strong ally in this fight
we have discussed the globe the way to
global
carbon pricing that would be ideal if we
have many supporters on
carbon pricing but of course also in
that context
how to sustain our competitiveness and
the question of industrial transition
and how to prevent carbon leakage
both canada and the european union have
an ambitious climate agenda
and we both know that it is not only
about
goals it's good to have good strong
goals ambitious goals
but it's about how to get to those
goals and there we offer to coordinate
closely before
glasgow because we need an ambitious
agreement on the internet with the
international community
to make glasgow the cop 26 a success
i very much welcome canada's commitment
to tackling the loss of biodiversity
and your decision to join the eu in
banning
single plastic use because we also need
to team up
on our way to kunming to the cop15
our planet needs us and it needs us to
set an ambitious global biodiversity
framework for the cop15 it should be
like the paris agreement but now for
biodiversity
speaking of sustainability we agreed on
building a strategic
partnership on raw materials we
as europeans want to diversify our
imports
away from producers like china because
we want
more sustainability we want less
environmental damage
and we want transparency on labor
conditions
these raw materials like for example
critical minerals and
metals are indispensable for the green
and the digital transition
on trade we had the occasion to reaffirm
our commitment
to the full implementation of sita it is
a crucial asset
for our economies on our way to recovery
and the figures are quite telling if you
look at 2019
trade between the european union and
canada increased by 25 percent for goods
and by 39 percent for services compared
to the
pre-seater levels so it is good for jobs
it is good for growth on both sides of
the atlantic
and for that we should work together to
solve the issues that
prevent ceta from unleashing its full
potential
for jobs and growth finally let me
mention
research as you know the next eu budget
for the next seven years is in place and
it includes a very substantial envelope
for research and innovation
our horizon europe program we invited
canadian researchers to participate in
our programs we want them
with us to intensify the exchanges
between our innovators for example
in bioeconomy advanced manufacturing
clean energy
digital technologies you just name it
and our canadians friends were happy
about this invitation so many many
thanks
to our friends and strong allies and a
very warm welcome again to brussels here
thank you madam president mr prime
minister
hello everyone mercedes
as you know over the weekend i was at
the g7 in cornwall with ursula and
charles
as we continue the fight to end covet 19
for good
we took a strong stance on major issues
including on
access to vaccines climate change and
global education
yesterday i took part in the nato summit
along with our allies here in brussels
the alliance is united and committed to
continuing its important work on
national and international security
we all agreed that we need to continue
to adapt to new security challenges
including climate change and cyber
threats
our world is at a unique moment in
history
and not only because of this pandemic we
must
stand united i'm encouraged by the
collaboration i've seen between our
friends and allies this week
and during my meeting with the european
union
our priorities are clear together
we must end this pandemic rebuild our
economies
and keep our people safe rebuilding our
economies means
thinking about the future with eu
partners we talked about what we can do
to build
a cleaner economy for years to come to
begin with
in order to continue creating good green
jobs for the middle class
we must secure supply chains for
critical minerals and metals that are
essential for things like electric car
batteries
that's why canada and the eu are
launching the strategic partnership
on raw minerals this new partnership is
focused on securing the supply of these
critical minerals
all while creating and supporting good
jobs
of course we can't talk about supply
chains without also talking about trade
agreements
on that front canada and the u eu are
continuing our partnership
under sita to create opportunities for
workers and businesses alike
on both sides of the atlantic during our
summit
we advanced our work to adopt a mutual
recognition
agreement that would simplify border
procedures while enhancing security
measures
this agreement will further speed up the
flow of trade between canada and the eu
and contribute to the safety and
security of all canadians
we know that we've worked very hard
together the europeans and canada
over the past number of years even as
other countries were slightly more
protectionistic
we were able to get many many things
done
during an uncertain time on the global
stage
which led us to strong advances for our
citizens
for our economies advances that we are
continuing to build on today as we move
forward at an even accelerated pace
our government will continue to ensure
all canadians benefit from these
progressive trade deals including
farmers
small and medium-sized business owners
women entrepreneurs
and the middle class that's what
building back better is all about
an economy that leaves no one behind
and at the heart of that more resilient
economy
is climate change
foreign
on the pond when it comes to health and
safety
job one remains ending this pandemic
and as we do that we have to continue
strengthening our health systems for
today
and for the future to support pandemic
prevention
preparedness and response we will launch
the canada eu dialogue
on health this will help canada and
europe share more information
identify emerging health threats and
work together to keep people healthy
including through mental health support
and on the subject
of the pandemic and vaccines i want to
pick up on what both
ursula and charles talked about and say
thank you
thank you not just to european leaders
but to
workers across europe who've been
getting
the world through this pandemic by
producing life-saving vaccines
canada's friendship and close alliance
with europe is certainly
something that we have counted on but we
will continue to work together to make
sure
that in the future canada continues to
be a strong partner to get us
all around the world through pandemics
like this
whether it's creating jobs or ending the
pandemic whether it's making our
economies more competitive in the
digital world or
standing up for our shared values around
the globe
together canadians and europeans will
continue to build
a better future
thank you mr prime minister we'll take a
few questions first in the room here
lewis blewen from radio canada please
thank you thank you for distraction but
uh we are totally convinced that uh
what you are trying to do uh this third
way proposed by in godzilla in the
framework
of the wto is the right approach because
uh the liberalization of the
intellectual property
will no be will not be the magic
bullet or the silver bullet i mean that
we need a more global approach we need
to take into consideration
the transfer to the transfers our
know-how the transfer
on technologies and it's exactly what
you are trying to do with the commission
uh to the decision to mobilize one
billion euros
especially for africa in order to work
on very concrete
projects and to take into consideration
this partnership between
the public authorities and the private
sector and to make sure that we can
increase the manufacturing capacities in
africa for example or in latin america
and it's very important for us to
diversify the supply chains
in the in the future but in the very
short term
the decision to liberalism to liberalize
immediately
the intellectual property is our opinion
will
not solve everything in the very short
term
globally
so indeed concerning
the trips agreement first of all there
are two proposals
now on the table of wto
one from india south africa and one from
the european union and we're working
closely together
to find a consensual approach to have in
the end a final text
because we share the same goal we want
that in a crisis like this pandemic
manufacturing possibilities and
capacities
rapidly can be brought to a region that
is at the moment being not in the
position to produce for example vaccines
now the question is what is the best
approach there was
the proposal of waiving ip rights
ip rights are the reward for
innovation and breakthrough research
and vip rights themselves do not
tell the whole story of how to produce
successfully a vaccine therefore
there is this new proposal on the table
to reach that common goal to have
compulsory
licensing in a crisis time like this
pandemic
of course today we have already a lot of
voluntary licensing
very successful but with this compulsory
licensing
you can combine that the
re-enumeration of the ip rights
is also decreased to the level
that is necessary for those countries to
manufacture
for example at no profit or low costs
and i've been speaking with cyril
ramaphosa during the g7
so i'm positive that we will find a
consensual text
that we reach our common goal that in
crisis times rapidly it's a matter of
speed
rapidly the possibility to manufacture
new vaccines is being brought
to countries or regions that do not have
it
and for that we are showing with our
initiative with
africa how this can work you need
the private sector the producing
companies
you need public investment for example
by the european member states or the
european commission
and you need support for the legal
framework the regulatory framework
where we are working with our african
friends on establishing
an african medicine agency that enables
the the creation of an ecosystem to
produce manufacturing
capacities the
companies like biotech pfizer or for
example johnson johnson are very
interested in this model
there's a lot of finances of private
investment that wants to go in these eco
schemes
what we do as a public sector is de-risk
this financing and therefore
enable the production of manufacturing
vaccines
i think what has been highlighted so
clearly
by my friends and colleagues here is
that this is a complex situation it's
not just a finding a single sig
silver bullet that's going to suddenly
result in
vaccines everywhere around the world
there are
complexities that need to be worked
through and canada from the very
beginning
has been engaged with our allies with
our wto partners
to ensure that that goal we all share
of getting people all around the world
vaccinated
safely and securely as quickly as
possible
is met using all the tools at our
disposal and that's something that is
shared by governments
all around the world by pharmaceutical
companies
uh by everyone who wants to see us end
this pandemic
everywhere so we can end it in each of
our countries
that's what canada has been working on
alongside our friends
and we will continue to next question
is for murray brewster from cbc
good morning good morning prime minister
i have a domestic
question for you we've had more
revelations in the military misconduct
crisis
and now a potential lawsuit from major
general
forte at what point does the government
get a handle on this and at what point
does the government consider the chaos
within the military and all of the
acting positions
to be a matter of national security i
think
first of all the situation has been
going on
for far too long that in the canadian
military like in many of our
institutions like in
many institutions around the world there
has been a culture that
has not adequately uh ensured the
protection of the women and men who
choose to serve
in our military we need for every
woman or man who serves in our military
to work in a workplace free from
harassment
free from intimidation and if ever it
happens
accessing the resources and the support
and the systems necessary to hold those
responsible to account
unfortunately canadian military
like many other militaries around the
world has had a culture that has
tolerated those kinds of
mistreatments and misbehaviors and what
we're seeing over these past
months is that
enough is enough now over the past year
since we came into office with
strong commitments to being a feminist
government to ensuring
protection and equality for everyone
we had taken significant measures
to support and protect anyone coming
forward
but what we're seeing now is that
those measures need to be increased and
accelerated which is why
we appointed uh lieutenant general
karina
to her role why we moved former chief
justice louis arbor
to oversee a wholesale culture change in
our military
and the further
issues that we're seeing are
illustrating that
as we well know there's still much more
work to do but i can assure
everyone that the continued capacity
of canada and its military to assure
our collective security continues to be
a top priority
[Music]
[Music]
0
yeah prime minister one follow-up to
that major general forte
in what was filed yesterday has said
that
he felt that his removal was arbitrary
and
i'm wondering if you're confident that
his removal was handled appropriately
i made a number of comments on this
situation when the news first broke
a few weeks ago but because it is now
before the courts i won't be making any
further comments
next question is for stephanie taylor
stephanie thank you prime minister
uh the other day you talked about as
more canadians get vaccinated
is when you will consider donating more
surplus vaccines
some countries are now looking at giving
their residents a third dose to boost
protection
so is canada considering giving away
surplus vaccines um before
is canada considering giving canadians a
third dose of vaccine and if so
will we be waiting to donate a surplus
until canada canadians get a third shot
thank you stephanie for your question uh
obviously uh
with the announcement we made at the g7
on 100 million doses that canada and 2
billion
through the g7 is directing
towards the rest of the world we are
already
recognizing as we have from the
beginning that even as we
vaccinate canadians we need to be
engaged in protecting the world which is
why
we moved forward quickly in partnerships
on kovacs
uh why we are one of uh you know the the
four
uh countries in the world including
germany and others that have
fulfilled and even surpassed our act a
commitments uh and we will continue uh
to ensure that we are
ending this vaccine uh everywhere so we
can end it in canada
there's virus everywhere so we can end
it in canada
every step of the way we have based our
decisions
on vaccinations on uh health measures
on the best advice of experts on the
um the recommendations
of our top scientists and doctors and
we will continue to do so and every
indication
is that fully vaccinate full vaccination
requires
two doses and that's what we're focused
on
[Music]
thank you president michelle i see that
canada
is not yet added to the european union's
tourism safe list it's white list and
international travel vaccine
certification is certainly something
i'm sure everyone all of you have been
speaking about and negotiating about
so what date can fully vaccinated
canadians
be able to come to europe for
non-essential travel
we have decided in europe to uh to
incorporate
and to decide on a kravitz certificate
with all the the members and we think
it's very important also to cooperate
with
third country you know to make sure that
uh in the next weeks in the next month
we can make progress in order to
to uh to re-establish the free movement
of people the free movement
of travelers we are working with the
commission with the european
parliament and with our friends
everywhere in the world in order to
try to develop a common approach
next question is for david hessenhorn
from politico david
thanks very much apparent uh mr prime
minister uh you mentioned the context of
your other
meetings that you participated in and uh
given the unpredictability of your
anglophone friends in recent years and i
don't just mean
trump or brexit you mentioned that the
vaccine issue where you found the eu
reliable
i wonder would you support greater eu
military integration
so that you might could you envision the
eu having military capabilities to the
point where your colleagues
would participate in nato summits as
they did
at the g7 or do you have other
priorities on which you'd like to see
canada and the eu
leading on the world stage um obviously
there are so many priorities in which
canada that
you are working together very closely
that
we're always looking for new ways to do
things together but
as the other founding transatlantic
member of the nato alliance
i can say that nato has been
extraordinarily impactful
in ensuring safety security of europe
not just in the cold war
but very much in a relevant way today
canada is
leading a battle group in latvia we're
present with troops in ukraine
we are part of and integrated into
european defense already in terms of
internal discussions that the eu may be
having with its member states and with
nato
i will leave that to them well maybe we
can ask the eu presidents their thoughts
but also if you could tell us a little
bit about
maybe your conversations on some of the
wrinkles that have come up as they
always do with
ceta and do you envision uh the com the
way you've been able to talk to canada
on the trade issues as a potential model
for working out uh some of the concerns
that have come up
in the trade agreement with the uk maybe
maybe one what about uh our cooperation
at the
level of defense we intend indeed to to
cooperate in order to
to to strengthen these very important
alliance
uh and indeed we have also tried at the
level of the european union to
we enforce the partnership with nato you
remember that
a few months ago installed participated
in a meeting of the european
uh council it's very strong signal that
we want to stand because
if we want a strong client it's very
important all the partners
are storing this one first point about
trade about the the city
probably the commission will react on
that but we
need the opportunity to observe the
important
progress made because of sata in both
interests canada but also the european
union and we had the opportunity to
discuss some more concrete topics in
order to task
our team and to try to solve some
some elements that are important for
canada
and for the european union this is the
way we cooperate and each
summit is the opportunity to identify
what are the next steps that are that
are needed and i remember that the last
summit between canada and the eu it was
the last summit in person it was
in the summer 19 we had identified some
topics
and we were very pleased yesterday
evening to observe that we had solved
the topic that we had identified in the
summer 19.
so um of course we know that
nato is the strongest military alliance
in the world
and the allies
also are aware of the fact that 22
member states
are part of nato
and if we speak about security and
defense
i think the content is broader than the
military aspect
the military aspect is important but the
context is much broader
we're speaking for example about
economic development or about
reconciliation
in conflicts or diplomatic influence
in conflicts which is also of utmost
importance reconstruction
one of the main pillars of global
security
and here the european union is playing a
very strong role
so there's a lot of complementarity
between nato and the european union and
then there is another aspect
as i was saying 22 member states are
the cornerstone of nato
and important is within
the european union a high degree of
interoperability
and to achieve that the european union
has created pesco
to make sure that future investments
are aligned and that we all
cherish from for example research and
innovation that come along with these
future investments and we also know that
there's an enormous spillover
into the civil industry civil research
and in
innovation and therefore it was a good
step forward to organize
the europeans in the pesco to make sure
that
development of military
equipment is harmonized and
has a common pursuit but as i said if
you look at both
entities the european union and nato
they are strongly complementary because
you need a broader approach
to the definition of security and what
ceta is concerned
i think it's in both our interest to
convince
our constituency and i've seen an
interesting number that the eu exports
to canada
are growing at a way stronger pace
compared
to the overall eu experts exports to the
rest of the world
so threefold more was the growth of
exports towards canada
than to the rest of the world and that
shows sita is working sita is good for
jobs ceta is good
for growth and this i think is
should be convincing to our
constituencies and also to the member
states who still have
to do some homework and is it a model
for discussions with the uk that you do
this on an unemotional
level when issues come up you know uh
that i've always said
uh i want a new beginning with old
friends
on what the uk is concerned um
we see that at the beginning now
there are difficulties and there are
serious
issues that have to be solved i'm deeply
convinced
with a constructive approach and with
the notion that we know it's a long-term
relationship
we are building here these issues can be
overcome
we know that withdrawal agreement and
the protocol are the best
we could have gotten in a complicated
situation it is
very good that we have the tca
and now it's our duty on both sides to
make sure that it works and to implement
it
i think this is our responsibility to
our people on both sides
thank you i'll take one more question um
from a dpa
verina verena schmidt are you there
yes good morning and thank you for the
question i'm very energetic with the
german press agency dpa
and uh following up on what you just
said uh my president from the line
i would like to ask you um what can be
done
concretely to overcome the hurdles for
ratification and full implementation of
sita
and if i may i also have a second
question
we understand there is a deal in the
works with the united states on
airbus and boeing tariffs maybe you
could
confirm this thank you yes so for
the first part of your question uh we
know that there are
practical i'd say just in teething
problems
and issues on both sides that we have
to fix and to overcome they are very
important
for certain constituency without any
question so this is our duty
to work on that and in the broader
context i think
the sita is self-explaining how
important and how good it is
so uh the the communication on that is
one of
uh the major steps forward um
what your second question is concerned
i am very positive that we will find an
agreement
on the airbus boeing issue today
in our conversation with our american
friends
i recall very well when i had my first
phone call with president biden must
have been in
february that at that point
we had agreed on finding a solution
on this aircraft dispute and
we we discussed possibilities we should
not underestimate this is
the longest trade dispute in the history
of wto so it's in our common interest to
solve it
and i'm very i'm very positive
and convinced that together we will
deliver today
thank you madam president mr president
and mr prime minister
we'll be publishing the eu canada
statement on our website so
please check that thank you for joining
us
you